hey guys what's up this is andrew from
sentences.com
so let's have a look at everything that
has happened this week amc gme
quite a negative move to close the week
on gme unfortunately we're gonna analyze
that and of course we're gonna have a
look at what is happening on the rest of
the market triple q guys i'm gonna show
you some things on tesla as well
and i wanna discuss um
the medium long term scenarios
to know if the bull market can start
again soon if yes what should we be
looking at to know if this is happening
or not
and try to give you my view on what
should what could happen i mean during
the summer and uh in september so let's
get into it
alright guys so amc first so as you can
see i kept my two scenarios here so
let's analyze the facts and then let's
try to
build up a view based on that so only we
can only looking at amc first
uh we're gonna go through first the
price action so you can see a trendline
is here it has been slightly moved guys
but
here we have almost perfect reaction so
this trend line is very valid to me just
connect the lows here
uh i don't really like to see a
consolidation close to the trend line as
you can see this is a consolidation the
price action is stuck
here which means that bears are putting
pressure on this trend line all right
so
it's not good
uh it shows that bears are very active
but for now both and control on uh i
mean if we just look at the price action
we're still above the uh major support
that is here created by this trend line
then second indicator we're going to
have a look at is the rsi what do you
guys can tell me by looking at this rsi
okay it's stuck below 50 right the 50
mark on the daily timeframe is
very good to use to know
who is in control very simple rule when
we are above 50 both in control when we
are below 50 bears and control so here
you can see we have
an information information that is um
a bit contradictory compared to the
price action because we have a momentum
rsi which is a momentum indicator that
is telling us based on control but the
price action is holding well above
support so you can already see we have
mixed signals
uh then
we can have a look at macd going higher
so this is uh rather bullish as well
macd positive okay this is not really
meaningful i don't use that a lot
um bam bam
what else do we have volume so it's
interesting to see that we had an
increase in volume on friday but we did
a very small move i mean
let's analyze that a little bit more
let's see if the volume happened on red
or green candles
a little bit of both on the hourly on
the first time frame if i go on the
hourly time frame all right the biggest
volume occurred at the close on the
green candle so that's rather positive
and the open was
red
and also increasing volume so
it's rather positive because the biggest
volume occurred on the green candle but
it's not a very strong signal i mean
this candle didn't go through any major
level right we are still stuck if i come
back on a daily timeframe we're still
stuck in this range
uh between i would say you know 11.5
right now and 13 13.3
you see we're still stuck in this range
so if we had a move here of this candle
that is taking back some important level
with this volume increase this would be
a called a breakout and you guys know
that breakouts are very good to use for
trading
i mean on emc it's a bit more tricky
let's be honest but it's still good
signal so here
once again this is some information that
is not very usable to me in terms of uh
building up view so to conclude
uh we are we have more bullish signals
which are volume and price action
holding above support then bearish
signals that are rsi stuck below 50 and
this consideration forming just above
the trend line uh so rather bullish so
we are rather in this bullish case that
i've that i have
that i drew uh two weeks ago or ten days
ago here
so for now this is what is happening so
let's see if we're able to go to this
area uh once again to answer that
question we need to look at the rest of
the market because right now the
correlation between amc or gme i mean
gme is not true for yesterday but most
of the times when we are in a difficult
market moves up occur together on every
stock
so amc gme tesla all of those move with
the rest of the market and
when everything is tanking there is no
exception for meme stocks as well when
we are in a bull market that's not true
we've seen that last year when we had
some strong moves down on the global
market spy triple q and we have seen amc
gme squeezing all right but the
situation is totally different so let's
forget about this negative better for
now
and try to
use what we have on triple 2 i'm going
to come to that very soon guys this is
very interesting so you need to see that
as well don't only look at jimmy and amc
but first let me do gme so
it's interesting to see once again
that
looks we
we've done the an analysis on
uh the rsi for amc
and you remember guys that we were
having
an rsi that was below 50 on dme guys you
can see that bulls are much stronger as
we have the rsi here that is on the uh
total opposite of amc holding
just above the 50 mark all right which
is clearly seen in this nice move up
that we had since
uh early may
um the question we have is is this move
finished or not i have labeled this one
two three four five here there is
another way to label it is like that
okay
so i was i was thinking of it so this
would be a third a little bit extended
this is possible as well for now we
didn't make a new high
but it's not excluded that if the rest
of the market pushes higher gme goes to
160 next week then probably get rejected
here
as you can see we can
make some kind of triangle all right we
have here a horizontal
resistance that is around 150 so if we
go above that we'll probably push 260
quickly so this is for some very
short-term trading
um
you can see that the support areas here
are not coming from a trend line maybe
we can do a trend line as well all right
it's not a beautiful trend line
but it's not too bad
no i don't like it
it's better to use the two in the moving
average you can see the price action is
supported by it one two three four times
yesterday the reaction was perfect
uh so this is our support created by
this 20-day moving average all right
um
let's be honest this is hard to trade
we are very close to this resistance
here the nice thing to do is to wait for
this major breakout and to buy some call
options or something like this you know
to play really um the move that could
happen right after that cool options
because once again we've seen in the
past that there were some fake outs here
so if you buy call options you just lose
your premium you're not stuck in a
position
uh that can lose you know on the
downside and you don't know how much
so
let's wait for now here i don't think
it's the right time to buy i would even
here reduce the position i know you guys
don't like to sell i'm just giving you
some
technical analysis
um
things that you can do based on the
uh different scenarios that i'm giving
you so here 160 is to me a resistance
and uh the 132
130 level roughly created by the 20 the
moving averages the support
um
once again it's hard to know what really
happened here if
the rest of the market gets really
bullish i mean
all right pretty
nice scenario that could happen on the
other hand
if we get one more leg down on the
global market which i'm afraid we will
um
all right something like that okay and
here would be a very nice level to buy
uh on this trend line around 100 level
roughly all right maybe in
i don't know one month something like
that so i think that this is what this
is what is awaiting us i don't see for
now
a breakout of this triangle and a strong
move up unless the rest of the market is
really bullish and let's have a look at
that so i'm going to give you my view on
the global market let's quickly just
remember
what is the situation the situation is
that we are correcting for the past six
months all right the collection has
started here
uh the reason of the correction was
the increase of interest rates the
tapering
um
and
there was no war at that time and we
were like all right this is gonna be i
was the first to tell you guys be
careful we have a breakout we're
probably gonna go to 280
uh on triple q around june this is what
i've told you guys here in december so i
was quite right about that
um and
the different uh but what happened and i
didn't know that at that time is the war
and the war created inflation in a way
that we can't control it anymore so this
is a new data that we didn't have back
in deck and that is making
the correction
i mean
likely to last longer than expected so
based on that
i'm afraid that
we are gonna move in five waves down so
one all right in red two three i'm not
sure the third is complete or not it
looks complete
okay
it looks complete because if we try to
break down
this third wave into five
okay i would do something like that
okay
so it looks like we have five waves in
this third wave
it's not very clear let's be honest but
let's analyze so uh first let me
conclude on that so it's looks to me so
maybe this is an abc
okay a five three five it's possible and
then we go higher
all right this is one scenario
and this is what i thought at the
beginning i thought we were in a big abc
correction
okay
and um
and what is happening
on the crypto market
with this you know luna thing celsius
the war that is going to last longer
the feds that is you know willing to
really increase rates at a
higher pace that
than they eventually wanted to do
so
creates to me new information that needs
to be taken into account in the market
and that
is going to be hard
i think in this environment this
macroeconomic environment for boost to
really take back control in the long run
so i'm rather thinking that we're gonna
have a deeper correction so based on
that view which is coming from
macroeconomics i might be wrong on that
totally you know we've seen the market
surprising us very positively just after
kovid when everybody was saying that
we're going to drop
further and that you know here during
this move up everybody was saying oh no
this is not going to hold
the the economic data is too bad
all right but we printed so much money
that the economic data became very good
and very quickly so we had this massive
rally
um so we always always need to be
careful when we analyze macroeconomics
because it's very hard to really predict
how
you know the economy will adapt to the
new environment but here
i mean
you know
we can't print we don't have any more um
really the fed cannot really take any
action to sustain the economy and
i mean maybe we're gonna have some
growth even in this uh inflationary
environment which would be a good way
to prove that the market is strong and
resilient and that maybe we can have
another leg up possible all right very
possible but for now this is not the
preferred scenario i have
um so i think that we're on a fourth
wave all right so as you can see the
second wave
lasted roughly two to three weeks
for now if this is the third wave it's
been only one week so we we potentially
might have
you know something like this an abc and
then go lower right so this is one
scenario
uh another scenario is that we get
rejected right away and that we have a
short false wave and then we go lower
all right this is another scenario and
then we would need to see
if this third wave was complete here or
maybe it's going to be complete a little
bit lower it's possible as well so what
i'm trying to say is that it's very hard
from here to know if this
move up that we have is the beginning of
a new move up but we're gonna analyze
that to me this is not this is not the
case or is it um a correction of a sub
wave or is it a force wave okay
so it's very hard to know that
but one thing we can say for sure
is
so let's analyze the price action that
happened here as you can see we have a
nice inverted head and shoulder that i
drew in yellow here okay
and we have here a breakout okay so this
pattern is a famous pattern uh i had
some questions from a member in the
platinum area when it was when it was
happening but we didn't have any volume
so you know you you can trade this
pattern whenever you have volume here
uh but on the short term
on the first time frame we didn't have
any volume during this breakout all
right you can see guys the volume is
totally dry
so
it was not
a good
um
play to me it it would have worked but
it was not a good player right what can
i say so
now
we have this
so usually
you guys know that uh we're gonna move
roughly so here we are 270
from the bottom to the head
of the head to the
bases there is 15 points and the basis
is at 285 so this should bring us
roughly to 300 this would be a validated
head and shoulder inverted head and
shoulder breakout
uh with the target of roughly 300 all
right first information but as you can
see the volume is very weak so this is
making this move weak and everything
that is weak in a bare trend like that
in the downtrend is usually attacked by
bells so let's see if bears attacked us
on monday
i think we still have a little bit more
room as you can see we have the target
at 300 and we have here a trend line
that i drew by connecting here the highs
and here one two three
connections
and this gives us a level of roughly
297 all right so 297 300 is an area
where we have
the target of the inverted head and
shoulder and we have some resistance
coming from the trend line all right
so i believe that this level is going to
be important either we get rejected
or we break out
if we break out we'll probably retest
and then maybe push to 315
before
either
dropping more
or
going higher right but i'm gonna analyze
that here and to know if once we arrive
at 315 we are likely to go higher or
um
or to dive more we're gonna need to
analyze
what is happening here all right do we
have volume on the way up first thing
second thing and this is the reason why
price action analysis is not enough in
this case
we would need to know is this market
ready to be bullish again so we're going
to need to analyze the macroeconomics
the situation inflation covered war this
things and we can look at the different
indicators that we have so we're going
to have a look at the vix you guys know
that vic's above 20 is bearish
so of course this is very bearish for
now we have a vix at 27.
if we arrive at 3 15
here
uh maybe in one month or two to three
weeks
um
we're gonna have a lot of information to
analyze like i said the volume but as
well how long are we able to stay here
and are we able to stop moving around
this level because if we always go up
and down strongly this is bearish guys
and to know if the market is quiet or
not you can look at the vix so once
again we need for bull market to start
again we need both the price action
analysis to tell us that booze and
control volume uh support resistances
momentum this kind of things plus we
need to see that the volatility is
dropping which is uh the indicator of
fear
and we can also have a look at
the reason of this uh bearish moves
which once again are coming from uh the
inflation which can be measured uh by
the u.s 10 year yield so as long as we
have a u.s tenure that is above 280 to
85 guys there is no reason this stops
all right this will probably
keep correcting because this is what is
creating the this bearish moves so once
again how to play that it's not easy
guys it's not easy i personally
took some protection
i am i'm i am now having a slightly uh
bearish position overall
i used
s triple q all right and here as you can
see so i started to buy uh a bit higher
started to buy at 53.5 right also here
okay on friday
um and i use a stop loss here so you're
gonna tell me yeah but you use a stop
loss here but we can very well be
bearish again afterwards yes true but
you need to put your stop loss somewhere
right otherwise you cannot
make big positions so i want to play
this if this is not working if we don't
have a bounce here
uh then
i don't know i will find something else
later
but for now i'm playing that which means
that
basically if we go above 300 on triple q
i'm gonna exit
my short position which might be a
mistake because if we go above that
level without volume we might very well
dive more but once again this is trading
and i stick to this method that
is making me use stop losses
even if there is not a clear signal to
get out of the trade but
once again
if you have a method that
uses stop losses you just need to stick
to that so this is what i'm personally
going to do once again i'm going to sell
roughly here i mean i sold already and
i'm just going to use a stop loss right
above this trend line which is on s
triple q right below this move and then
i'm going to see either we drop more on
triple q
and at least i'm protected or
we come back here so i'm gonna stop my
position at the beginning
and then i'm gonna probably try to
reload around 315. here i'm going to
build up another short position with the
stop loss maybe just above
um
and if i see that we have strong volume
here
and you know that everything is cooling
down and that the macroeconomics are
doing better i'm gonna start to slowly
reduce my short position so there is no
magic formula of course guys
this is really tough uh to trade uh this
market is full of tricks
uh the reason being that there is no
direction no one really knows what's
going to happen i mean you can't say
whatever you want the truth is that
every day his new information every day
uh is
bringing us
uh he's telling us what is the sentiment
in this market for now the sentiment is
clearly bearish guys
we have some strong strong moves up on a
very low volume
this is not bullish uh we have a lot of
uncertainty we still have vx very high
us 10 yield above three dx y above 103.
right so all of that is telling me that
we are not out of trouble and once again
if um you ask me when are we gonna be
out of trouble and how would you know
that so first i don't know anything for
sure
but second i would tell you guys that we
need time all right there is it's not a
question of levels
uh if we strongly go to 3 40
in a matter of one week this would not
be bullish guys this would be crazy and
probably bearish to go higher that fast
especially if we are no volumes it's not
a question of level is we need to go
above 315
quietly with the vix that is dropping
good news coming from the
news flow macroeconomics
uh the u.s 10 yield that is dropping you
know telling us that inflation is under
control
and all of that guys it's a
process that cannot be only read on
charts and charts here definitely help
but we are in a situation where we need
to aggregate all the information we have
and try to build up a view based on that
and make some traits been based on
technicals and macroeconomics so it's
really
i mean it's trading right it's very
exciting but it's really tough it's not
easy to make money so i personally don't
go big with my positions because i know
this is very tricky
um and i think that the best thing would
be that we have a real drop that we
purge and we come back to the you know
230 200 ariane triple q and here you
know you just reload massively i mean
you know what can happen once we're here
so this is the easy trade i'm not sure
it's gonna happen this is what i i'm
personally playing
i think that unfortunately we're gonna
see this low levels
sooner or later
before of course bouncing uh from there
so that's it for today i hope oh tesla
tesla
same thing uh you can see
we are playing around you know the 700
level here that was a strong support we
went below above below now we have a
breakout with this trend line
on low volume i mean it's very hard to
play
i don't know what to think i think that
we're gonna drop to 500 at some point i
don't know when
uh and of course i can change my view if
i see that we managed to break out above
the 1100 level so here i have a level
because i have a nice trend line uh we
are so far from that guys so for now
um i personally don't have any tesla
shares and i will only start to
accumulate at lower levels and if i miss
that move and if we're in a strong bull
market
uh i will find a way to enter you know
on a dip once the bull market is
confirmed all right it's so much easier
to trade during a bull market than right
now i prefer just to be patient so
that's it for today i hope you guys
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget to click on the sub like
and bell button so you're going to be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to show see you guys